verwijdering van de galblaas zogenoemde
cholecystectomie wordt gewoonlijk
uitgevoerd wanneer het tekenen zijn van
groot stenen of ontsteking van de
galblaas
symptomen van een galblaas aandoening
gewoon het bestaande uit pijnaanvallen
in de rechter bovenbuik
tweede voornamelijk op wanneer galsteen
een tijdelijk een van de twee galwegen
blokkeren die gal van de galblaas naar
de darm voeren
als de stenen niet passeren kan er
zwelling ontsteking of infectie van de
galblaas optreden wat kan leiden tot
ernstige symptomen zoals misselijkheid
braken en koorts
met nieuwe laparoscopische technieken
ook bekend als kijkoperaties zijn er
slechts kleine insnijdingen nodig en is
de herstelperiode veel korter voor de
ingreep wordt er een intraveneus infuus
aangelegd en kan men nu een kalmerend
middel geven om u te helpen ontspannen
laparoscopische cholecystectomie wordt
uitgevoerd onder volledige narcose
zodat u slaapt gedurende de gehele
operatie
hierdoor ontspannen de spieren van de
buikwand zich zodat de chirurg ruimte
heeft om te werken via uw mond wordt er
tijdelijk een ademhaling slang in uw
killing gebracht om u te helpen ademen
tijdens de operatie
er kan ook een maag slang via uw mond in
de maag worden ingebracht
om te helpen daar geproduceerde
vloeistoffen af te voeren
in de meeste gevallen duurde ingreep 30
tot 60 minuten om bij de galblaas en
omliggende structuren te kunnen
gebruiken chirurg scherpe instrumenten
zogenoemde trok aars om een reeks kleine
openingen in de maagwand te maken een
van deze openingen bevindt zich gewone
bij de navel
vervolgens wordt er kooldioxidegas door
de opening bij de navel gepompt om uw
buik op te pompen zodat inhoud beter
zichtbaar is
vervolgens brengt de chirurg de
laparoscoop in
door de opening bij de navel de beelden
afkomstig van de camera in de
laparoscoop worden geprojecteerd op een
videoscherm in de operatiekamer
de chirurg gebruikt andere instrumenten
ingebracht via de verschillende
openingen om de galblaas vast te grijpen
de hoofdslagader en de galweg los te
snijden en deze in een specimen zakje te
plaatsen dat wordt verwijderd door een
van de openingen alvorens ze laparoscoop
te verwijderen kijk de chirurg of
verbloeding of ander letsel is na het
verwijderen van de laparoscoop wordt er
nog even een klep in een van de
openingen opengelaten om alle
kooldioxide uit de buik te laten
ontsnappen
tot slot worden de insnijdingen gesloten
met hechtdraad of nietjes
en afgedekt met verband
na de operatie worden de ademhaling
slang en maag slang verwijderd en wordt
u naar de herstel kamer gebracht waar u
wordt bewaakt
u krijgt pijnmedicatie als dat nodig is
en u gaat geleidelijk over van vloeibare
op zachte op vaste voeding het
intraveneus infuus wordt verwijderd
wanneer uw spijsvertering systeem
hersteld is
de meeste patiënten kunnen na elektische
ofwel niet-acute cholecystectomie binnen
24 uur naar huis patiënten met een
geïnfecteerde galblaas moeten mogelijk
een of twee dagen langer blijven